>>James Schiro - Davos Debates 2009 (Environment)
Hi YouTube. I'm Jim Schiro the CEO of Zurich
Financial Services. About three weeks ago
we announced a significant climate change
initiative at Zurich. I know many people are
concerned about, given the current financial
crisis, will a lot of these climate change
initiatives get back to the back burner. I'm
confident that that's not going to happen.
I think that it's extremely important that
climate change become part of the solution
to restore economic growth with the establishment
of innovations and creativity. We've begun
offering products around insuring carbon capture
methods. We've also announced a reduction
of 10% of our own carbon footprint during
this period in time. I think these are cost
saving methods that will help us in our business,
but I also think people are too aware at this
point in time of the danger the climate is
in to take a back burner. So I'm confident
that as long as CEO's keep this on the agenda,
we won't lose out during this current crisis.